how's it going everybody it's Warren and
we have some potential spoilers for
Avengers endgame so remember how D and
Robert Downey jr. sort of let it slip
that Tony Stark gets back to earth
somehow you know I need to drive it
right well I mean I as Tony Stark in
Avengers 4 out in theaters spring 2019 I
did but this is us now buddy
obviously Tony's not going to drive an
Audi in the middle of space so he
obviously gets back to earth somehow but
I mean it's safe to assume that Tony
Stark is going to get back to earth so
not really a big spoiler there but a
spoiler nonetheless yeah well it turns
out that Audi is at it again so in the
consumer electronics world there is a
convention called CES stands for
Consumer Electronics Show and Audi was
at this show and at the show they had an
in-car reality experience well in this
in Carver Chua we allottee experience
there was an Avengers in game tie-in
called Marvel's Avengers rocket rescue
run and this was developed by Disney
games and interactive experiences and in
this game players take on the role of
Rocket Raccoon as he pilots a ship
through an asteroid field so did he just
tell us through this game that rocket is
the one that goes and saves Tony Stark
in space although this is not an
official confirmation let's look at all
of the facts and logic that point to
this actually being true well to start
off its called rocket rescue run who
would he be going to rescue and he has
to fly through an asteroid field so we
know he's going through space in reality
rocket isn't going on this rescue
mission to save Tony Stark he doesn't
even really know who he is but him and
Groot left the Guardians who are his
family Groot decimated but he has no
idea what happened to the rest of the
guardians of the galaxy and they're his
family they're really all that he has so
of course he's going to go off and try
to find them to see if they're okay and
I mentioned this in a past video but
rocket is probably the only one who
could actually track down the benatar as
we know rocket is one raccoon who is
very sophisticated in technology so
nobody really knows where Tony Stark is
and they can't track him but rocket can
track down the Minotaur
which Tony Stark is on and once he gets
there he can probably save Tony as I
mentioned in one of my previous videos
Rocket has a tool that he used in
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 to repair
the ship but ultimately that could be
irrelevant because he could just pull
Tony Stark aboard his ship unless it's
too small then he could in fact repair
the benatar one of the last clues that
points to this being true is the fact
that Rocket is nowhere to be found in
the Avengers end game teaser trailer
this is most likely due to the fact that
he left earth to go and find the
guardians of the galaxy and they're
showing Tony dying lost in space in the
teaser trailer they're obviously not
going to show Rocket Raccoon if he's in
space somewhere that would give it away
so again the logic and the facts behind
this make it a very high probability
that rocket is going to be the one to
save Tony Stark and again the virtual
reality game is titled rocket rescue
mission so that's a pretty big giveaway
as it is but let me know what you all
think about this do you think that
Rocket Raccoon is going to be the one to
save Tony Stark even though technically
he's going to save the guardians of the
galaxy or do you think that rocket
rescue mission could be referring to
something else in the movie let me know
your thoughts in the comments down below
and I'm giving away a life-sized
Infinity Gauntlet if you would like to
enter for your chance to win all you
have to do is subscribe to my channel
like this video and comment down below
with your thoughts and your favorite
superhero as always thank you all so
much for watching Wolf Wolf
[Music]